the second part of our first one and
sewing linear queries which understand
will be split between Sasha oh and
Jerome who also goes by Sasha so yes so
we'll pick up where we left off yeah
thank you alright so I ended on this
note that we have this matrix mechanism
which in some sense is the best you can
do if you have a very large database but
when you have a small database there are
better things you can do in particular
if your database is very small you see
if you do something like just add
Gaussian noise with some distribution
your database really see like very small
has a like one or two rows you may be
able to just do better by like
outputting something without leaving
looking at the database should be clear
there for very small databases you can
have what sort of less error but of
course we will talk about smarter
mechanisms which kind of try to stay
closer to the optimal error or at least
get reasonable error in this regime of
like small databases okay so start with
one method which is still kind of feels
like kind of data independent but it
starts to get some data dependence and
to do better things with small databases
which is the projection mechanism so
let's remember some things we were
encoding or databases this histogram and
we were saying which just gives us for
every possible database type how many
rolls of that type they are in the
database and we observed that if you add
up all the coordinates of this vector
which is just which is what it's l1
normos if you add up the coordinates of
this histogram you just get n so okay so
if the database can size at most and
then this like some of the coordinates
of the histogram is at most n so and we
said given a query matrix the vector of
query answers is just the product of the
square matrix and the histogram okay and
and H a lot H is a vector of l1 norm at
most one
and this remembers my notation for all
vectors of l1 norm at most one so you
have that this vector of query answers
has to be in the image of the set of all
vectors with this l1 norm x w right but
remember okay so the so this set of all
vectors of l1 norm at most M it just n
times the like it just the set of all
vectors with everyone on it at most 1
multiplied by n ok and I can always pull
out the end in front right and remember
this is just what I call my sensitivity
pollito so in other words I have this
set which contains all possible query
answers on databases of size at most n
this is this is the set and it just
turns out to be exactly n times the
sensitivity polytope but think of this
is just the set of all possible query
answers on databases of sizes at most n
ok so I I know that my to query answers
lie somewhere here if I just add like
data or like right if we just add data
independent noise like say say just run
the Gaussian noise mechanism I'll
compute the true query answers and add
some Gaussian noise if n is very very
small then this set of possible query
answers is also small and it could be
that this is so much Gaussian noise that
I'm very likely to get outside of this
set and I get a vector of like noisy
query answers which could not have
current weight which which is not in the
set of possible actual query answers
right so at this point is very natural
to even just to make the queries more
like the query and is more
understandable it's very natural to
project back into this feasible set of
possible query answers
it's a very natural thing to do and this
is what the projection mechanism does
and this is from again this paper with
kunal and D Jack the projection
mechanism is just run the regular
Gaussian noise mechanism to get your
noisy query answers
and then find the closest point inside
the set of possible query answers will
do this in Euclidean norm in like Oh 2
norm find the closest point inside the
set of possible query answers to the
noisy query answers okay so if the
Gaussian noise didn't get you outside of
this set you just stay there or you just
output that but if it took you outside
you project back to the closest point
that's actually feasible that could have
actually come what could have actually
been an answer to these queries and and
this is the point at your output this is
the output of the projection mechanism
good and the point is that we already
achieve privacy by adding the Gaussian
noise and we then we don't touch the
data again in this mechanism so this
projection just post-processing it's a
very natural post-processing so it does
not affect privacy because you know
differential privacy is robust s-- to
pause processing okay so what what's
surprising maybe is that this projection
is not just kind of a sensible thing to
do and maybe it makes the query answers
like easier to explain but it also could
reduce error at least in certain
parameter regimes so I initially was
thinking of showing this proof but I
realized maybe this would be a little
too many inequalities on the board I
really like this proof but anyway said I
will not end up showing it so using a
little bit of high school geometry
basically like just geometry triangles a
little bit of probability you can show
that the mean squared error so so far we
were talking mostly about worst case era
but remember there was this notion of
mean squared error where I took the
squared errors and I averaged them over
the different queries so the mean
squared error you can show is bounded by
square root of the database size
remember these are normalized counting
queries by the square root of the
database size times this power of the
log of the universe size and this is
actually working relatively easy proof
kind of using this observation that if
you look at this triangle these are the
true query answers these are the noisy
query answers and this is the projection
it must be that this angle is right or
obtuse and like you work with that a
little bit and eventually with some work
you can derive that yes so this
he's like the square root of the mean
squared error the root mean square error
I should have should have said I tried
to make everything on the same scale so
like this is this is on average how much
error like think of this is the average
error this is an average cometary you
you get per query I was taking this
query oh and there are some things for
which this is optimal even even for this
way root of the mean squared error again
another result of John Mark Bannon so
they've all done is that this is optimal
even for mean squared or root mean
squared error for two-way marginals and
this was our example where we saw that
the matrix mechanism doesn't do always
as well as we would hope but then you
can do this so you can do some simple
post-processing and just even just on
top of the Gaussian mechanism into quite
well and again the projection does not
affect privacy but it could improve the
error bounds if if your database is
small because that's exactly the case
where the Gaussian noise takes you
outside and then you go back in and that
can actually sometimes improve the error
bounds not you know any in and it never
makes the error worse is play you
something that's important to say so the
error never becomes worse and can
sometimes improve a lot and the other
thing I want to say is this
post-processing sort of terms of data
independent mechanism it was just the
Gaussian noise mechanism to something
that sort of is data dependent because
if I start from here add noise and
project this would be a different
distribution then if I start from there
add noise and project yes
what the barrier about small end so what
do you mean by small and definitely the
the data independent methods so I'll
just add noise with some distribution
methods they they seem to be close to
optimal when you have more data than the
number of work much more data than a
number of queries let's say like number
of queries over epsilon here this
actually kicks in and starts to be
better maybe even earlier than that but
uh so all I could put like a particular
queries it like these data dependent
things could be better even for larger
and I mean what I'm actually saying let
me think about it
so when n is less than square inches and
opera Queens
divided by love this thing right that
projection is there this thing
I like in general the data independent
things do quite well when n is at least
number of queries over Epsilon
let me just say that and I guess they
could still be competitive even for
smaller end but in general they're not I
mean like the data independent things
yeah I think the rule of thumb is more
data than queries okay good
let me I think I think it's important to
say so let me talk a little bit about
something that's important that I
haven't been talking about it also so
far I've been assuming that all these
scouting queries to just give them by
their truth table so I've just for every
counting query really listed for every
possible row in the database what is the
value of the query but of course often
in practice the queries are specified in
some implicit way then you don't just
list all their values from the whole
universe you have something like our way
marginals we saw one in two way margins
I think you can now in four would like
three and four way margin those are I'm
not going to define it explicitly
because I don't use them but you know
you have things like this that are like
very compactly specified you can imagine
a query specified like a little circuit
for example like a little formula like
some compact expression and then in
those cases you definitely also because
usually the universe is huge you would
want to have algorithms that achieve the
same kind of error bounds that I was
that I've been talking about but in much
much faster time and going back to this
seminal paper Cynthia moanin or Oh
marigold Garros woman salute overdone we
know that in general getting non-trivial
error bounds in time that's the blini
err in the size of the universe is
computationally hard under some
reasonable complexity theory assumptions
right so if I just hand you a circuit
that specifies like a bunch of circuits
that specify the queries then doing
anything non-trivial in time much faster
this could be computationally hard but
they show this for a relative like
relatively artificial families of
queries if you have like very natural
specific families of queries like
two-way marginals 3-way marginals we
still don't really know what we can do
in time this polynomial in the dimension
of the data rather than the universe
size which is more like 2 to the D and
say the database size and for two-way
marginals in fact we could have a more
efficient algorithm using the projection
mechanism so let me talk about this a
little bit so you get protection
mechanism you just add Gaussian noise
project on to the set of feasible query
answers so clearly adding Gaussian noise
is not the expensive step this we can do
very efficiently the expensive step is
projecting and with a little bit of work
using sort of known results in
optimization you can reduce projecting
on the set of feasible query answers to
solving linear optimization problems
over the sensitivity polytope ok so if
you can solve this linear optimization
problem for an arbitrary linear
objective where the feasible set is the
sensitivity polytope then you can also
project you can do this using the FIFO
algorithm and other methods as well
however you can think what is the
sensitivity polytope for two-way
marginals it's not very hard to describe
kind of theoretically
then you can take what is what what does
it mean to solve these sorts of
optimization problems over the
sensitivity polytope for two-way
marginals and you realize that you can
encode maxcut this way ok so you realize
this is an np-hard problem ok so that
sort of seems like a no-go but the
simple idea is not to project on the
sensitivity polytope but project on some
larger set on which we can project
efficiently ok so in this paper with
Cynthia and now we we show that you can
come up with sort of a relaxation L of
the sensitivity polytop relaxation
because it strictly contains it well
it's not much larger so it's contained
in just a constant times the original
sensitivity polytope so it's like almost
the same size but using a semi definite
program you can actually project
efficiently
meaning in time polynomial in the
dimension of the data on L on this
relaxation l okay so this is sort of a
cartoon of what this looks like and this
way because L is only slightly larger
than sent the sensitivity polytope you
get essentially the same results as the
projection mechanism for the actual
sensitivity polytope but you get them
efficiently as in again or in on your
time in the norm in the dimension of the
data
yes Alan is you know Adam is even
produced what you said was clear right
so I had a question about what hardness
for max cuts they really implies here
does it imply that I mean obviously
implies it's hard to do this projection
exactly yes does it imply does it you
know if I do hardness of approximation
results for mexica tell you you can't
get close to the polytope is there like
core it it like just your notions of
approximation Trent translate naturally
here I would have to think more about
that I'm not not sure yes I think this
order one except we sort of we do some
other things and it's more like the
growth in the cost but yeah kind of
roughly the the gamos Whitham some
constant yeah those do seem related i
think it's like finding this relaxation
definitely is essentially the same as
like finding a good efficient relaxation
of the max cut problem but just what
this hardness means and hardness of
approximation is there any reason to
think that it practice it's actually
hard to get on topology you know
projection so i think you can you can
you can do things like like in dual
vector you can use some solvers and just
hope it works well and i think that
seems very reasonable i should say at
least in theory so in practice then you
can hope to do that also for three-way
marginals with some solvers but in
theory we don't know an algorithm which
is efficient in terms of dependence
animation and does this kind of thing
for three or marginals we don't know how
to like write these semi-definite
programs sir
there's like some evidence that the
usual ways to do that don't work so this
is a frustrating challenge that I think
like many of us give struggle with I
will
I think skip this so that I don't cut
too much into sorry it's almost if he's
here so that I don't cut too much into
Jerome's time and you say something else
so I talked about this projection
mechanism but it was just
post-processing on top of the Gaussian
noise mechanism but we also talked about
other ways to add noise that's
independent of the data which was the
matrix mechanism so you could try to
combine the two you could try to both do
this factoring of the queries into
reconstruction and strategy queries
answer the strategy queries reconstruct
and then project onto the set of
feasible answers this is a very
reasonable thing to combine both of
these and now of course the question
would be how do you find the right
factorization and you would want to you
know take some upper bound on how well
noise plus projection does and minimize
that and you can try to go through all
of this I won't do this in as much
detail as it did it for the matrix
mechanism but you can and this is
another result from the same paper and I
have some improvements in a later paper
you can show that doing these sorts of
things with some caveat that the
projection actually is a little bit
different from what I described you can
show if you get a mechanism whose error
is like close to the optimal error for
every N and for every set of queries but
close to the optimal is up to these
factors which are logarithmic an N which
I think is not so horrible but also
logarithmic in the size of the universe
and the size of the universe is usually
enormous it's usually kind of
exponential in the natural dimension of
the data so this is a factor which is
more like the dimension of the data so
it looks good when you put it there with
a log if you're like a theory person you
think logger logs are good things but
it's really a log of an exponential
thing so it's not
as great as it could be and it's open to
not have this log of universe's eyes
there and I should say this is only for
sort of this route of mean squared error
we don't have similar results for worst
case error and I think that's also nice
if you write a couple problem now let me
finish with let me finish sorry with the
final class of algorithms which are
really kind of data dependent and are
hella take a different viewpoint which
is more like the viewpoint of trying to
learn the databases you're answering or
in order to answer your accounting
queries so the things we saw saw so far
especially in the morning or sort of
tools to answer sort of a small number
of queries on a large database okay
there we saw that this data independent
nodes works well so one idea would be
can you given a large workload of
queries can you try to reduce answering
all of them to answering a few of them
can you try to answer a few of these
queries and generalize from there to all
the rest of the queries and I think this
viewpoint maybe can be traced back at
least implicitly to this very seminal
work of Blum Ligety Roth at least sort
of this viewpoint so let let me
introduce some notation which I hope is
not too confusing so the way I think
about this is like with these algorithms
you can think of the database is
actually being a function that assigns
to every query its value okay it's to
like just a notational difference really
Oracle or syntactic difference but I
think is helpful to think of the
database this way is a function from
queries to query answers did you trying
to learn
okay so I'll have this notation which is
you know I'm just switching what is
inside the parentheses what is outside
so but all I'm saying is think of the
database is a function that assigns to
the query
it's answer and now the goal would be to
sort of take a few examples of queries
and answers really those who have to be
noisy and from those few examples learn
the entire function that map's you know
all the queries to their answers
approximately so way number one to do
this is based on boosting so let's say
you have some mechanism with good mean
squared error guarantee so let's say the
root of the mean squared error is ADA so
the average of the squared errors is
bounded by a2 squared let's say I have a
mechanism like that and I'll try to get
from there to having small error on all
the queries so this is the kind of thing
that with projection we can do well even
on like many queries and you first can
observed it just sort of by Marco for
weight Markov sort of Championships
inequality
knowing that the average squared error
is small means that for most of the
queries the error is small so say with
these numbers I can say that for all but
1/4 of the queries the error is bounded
by twice this era in other words what I
have is that I can approximate the query
answers I can approximate this like
function with this database function
which maps queries to query answers on
most of the queries I know what it has
on most of the queries so in some sense
I have what weekly learning this
function I want to strongly learn this
function that is learning on all of the
queries here so this is very non
technical writer on a very high level
this sort of reduction of week of strong
learning two-week learning was done by
for initial period back in the night is
who designed this sort of framework of
boosting which allows you very
generically to give strong learners
based on having weak learners for some
concept class that you're trying to
learn it and there is a version of this
due to Cynthia cutoff bloomin salute
photon which is private boosting which
kind of similarly reduces worst case
error to mean squared error so using
private boosting you can run a base
mechanism with good mean squared error
or relatively small number of times and
from that extract mechanism with good
worst case error and you can apply this
for example to this projection based
mechanism for two
marginals and also get optimal or
essentially optimal worst case error
even in right like you we I talked about
how do you how do you get very good mean
squared error turns out that that mean
square error is also a close to optimal
and using boosting you can also get good
worst-case error again quite close to
optimal and all of this is efficient if
the base algorithm is efficient then the
boosted algorithm is essentially as
efficient as well this is learning
approach number one learning approach
number two is just to recap from Rachel
stock yesterday afternoon so this is the
private multiplicative voice mechanism
so the viewpoint here is that we're
going to view the database maybe less is
a function more more is a probability
distribution that we're trying to learn
so the observation is just if I look at
this histogram and I divide every entry
by n then I just get a probability
distribution on the universe and this
probability distribution is just for
every universe element X every possible
database row what is the fraction of the
database that is equal to this database
row so this is just the empirical
distribution of the database so it kind
of normalized histogram and we said
before that the counting query answers
are given by this product of the query
matrix and the histogram
if I divide everything by n this is the
same as the query matrix times the
normalized histogram so these these are
just the normalized query answers these
are just normalized counting queries
were instead of asking how many rows in
the database satisfy a predicate
I'm asking what fraction of the rows in
database satisfy predicates and if these
normalized queries if I get error alpha
this is the same as getting error alpha
n for the unnormalized queries okay now
for like any probability vector P any
like kind of possible normalized
histogram I'll use this notation Q of P
for basically just the coordinate of
this matrix vector product that
corresponds to Q and this is really just
let me pretend that be
is the normalized histogram what would
be the normalized counting query answer
and you can see because P prep resents X
will try to learn P in order to answer
the queries that we care about and this
is real recap of yesterday so this is
the private multiplicative voice
mechanism I think what Rachel described
was closer to what was actually here in
this paper by Harlan Roth boom which was
an online mechanism our described sort
of the offline version of it which is in
a slightly later paper it's a little
simpler to analyze it I think right so
the strategy will be will like try to
keep guessing what the correct
distribution is we'll start for some
from some uninformed guests which is the
uniform distribution over the universe
and we'll try to keep improving this
guess as long as we're making a mistake
somewhere if we're not making a mistake
then we are done so this will proceed in
rounds in every round I'll try to
privately find the query so that the
true query answer and the query is given
by my current guess is wrong by more
than alpha if I cannot find one then I'm
done then my current guess for the
distribution is clearly good enough for
all the queries that I care about so I
can stop but if I do find the query on
which I'm doing badly then I just update
my guess of the correct distribution in
some way that allows me to like say that
I can that I'm making progress that I've
learned from my mistake and I can
improve my guess okay so this query is
what I call the distinguisher between
the true normalized histogram and our
current guests and you can find a
distinguishing query just by just
running the exponential mechanism with
the score which is just the error so
this is just the true query answer this
is the thing that sensitive - the thing
that's given by my current guess in
absolute value so this is just the error
that I'm making on this query and it was
one query with this core function and
you can see the sensitivity is one over
and here because the
sensitivity of this normalized query
answer is 1 over N and that determines
the sensitivity of the score and the
update rule is this multiplicative way
it's a bad rule where intuitively what's
happening is the following
so let's just take one egg like one case
of this where let's say the current gets
overshoots so it's way too large then
the sign of the difference between the
tracker and the current guess is
negative so what I'm doing is I'm taking
the probability of any element of the
universe that contributes to the query
and I'm decreasing this probability by a
multiplicative factor and then I'm
renormalizing so that I have a
probability distribution again ok so if
my current guess is too large then I
look at all the things that contribute
to the query and I just decrease those
probabilities and I'll do the opposite
thing if I make an error in the other
direction and like a very brief sketch
of why this works so the claim is that
you can answer this the normalized
queries with error alpha which is the
same as the unnormalized queries without
error alpha n as long as n is at least
this big which translates to the same
kind of error bounded we've seen before
but in the worst case so the error is on
the order of like square root of n times
square root of log K times this fourth
power of log of the universe size and
roughly how this is shown is you use a
potential function which is the relative
entropy between the true distribution
and your and your guests okay this is
what relative entropy is it's also known
as KL divergence initially our initial
guess is the uniform distribution so
this is an initiative log of universe
size and is always non-negative those
are just facts about relative entropy
and we can show that every update with
the update we chose decreases the
relative entropy by at least alpha
squared over 4 so we can do it most this
many updates so this is a bound on the
number of times we need to run the
exponential mechanism and this is really
the only way we're touching the data is
running the exponential mechanism and
from this standard standard analysis of
exponential mechanism plus advanced
composition you can derive this error
bound
okay and I'll stop here here a bunch of
things I did uncover yesterday we heard
some talks about from session Rachel
about synthetic data you can use pretty
much particularly ways to get synthetic
data there are other ways as well I
didn't talk much about that you can it's
very interesting to answer sort of
adaptively post queries online the
private multiplicative Waits mechanism
can be adapted to do that but sort of
this rich theory of like you like
achieving optimal error in different
regimes there is not much of that known
and there also other methods to answer
like implicitly defined queries
efficiently some very interesting work
this is just one example paper there are
a few more based on low degree
polynomial approximations of this
function that we're trying to learn I
didn't talk about lower bounds much and
sorry John and I didn't talk much about
applied work but we hear more from
jerome about that stop here I didn't
really I I was just saying I presented
this version of multiplicative weights
we'll use the exponential mechanism and
I was saying if you want to make it
online you can use above threshold right
this what I'm calling the above
threshold mechanism I think it's what
you called it in the book No am i
confused
but as far as vector always sparse
vector yes
such a well journalist
setting up the kind of these is out the
algorithms you mentioned where you can
they also be viewed as some sort of
matrix like P matrix mechanism like
thing but then and some way to think
about I think you can view them as John
yes yes I say yes I think so yeah it's
like I guess it is like approximating
the query matrix we have smaller matrix
right yes I'm so yeah it's like a
low-rank approximation to the query
matrix like it's everything is sort of
still linear okay everything is linear
in the right way I think so yes all
right so it's rolling mclubbe from there
mass Amherst who's done a lot of
greatsword a theoretical hand applied
work on this topic and it's gonna give
maybe since Sascha presented like the
theoretical view on the matrix mechanism
I assume Tyrell will present like the
apply for you on on saucers name
something like that thank you
yeah and Ryan McCann is gonna help out
in the middle so I'm gonna focus on the
same task that Sasha focused on batch
sometimes known as non interactive
career answering of a workload of linear
counting queries and as he told you
linear counting queries are good for
lots of lots of things and I want to
take a moment to sort of address where
the workload might you know might come
from and because I view this as part of
the a desirable interface for a
differentially private mechanism that a
user or stakeholder somebody who's
studying the data will express their
needs and preferences through in through
choosing a workload and it may be that
they have a more complex data analysis
task in mind maybe fitting a model but
they can decompose that into a set of
sufficient statistics that are linear
accounting queries it could be that a
set of multiple users are
down to a single pricey budget and so
they have to sort of each they're each
interested in slightly different things
or maybe overlapping things and they put
it all together into a workload or you
may not know exactly what you want to
know and we know that you know we can't
preserve accuracy for everything so
we're you know it's okay if we over over
our estimate what you know what we're
interested in a little bit and put that
in as the workload and we'd like to have
mechanisms that do the hard work for us
given a user who's expressed that
workload okay so what I'm gonna try to
talk about is more applied an informal
view of algorithm landscape and I will
there will be a little bit of review
here but I think it'll be useful to see
some of the data agnostic and matrix
mechanism type techniques from a
different perspective then I'll and the
data dependent mechanisms then I'll talk
about a use case from the Census which
is kind of a live use case based on work
that we're doing with the Census and
that would be a good time to break if I
can get through that stuff it's a
suspenseful moment because I'll ask you
a rhetorical question and then Ryan will
help answer the rhetorical question and
then we'll see what happens on the
census workload and come back to that
adaptive algorithms and some more
empirical results okay so here's so I'm
going to present two approaches and and
this is for just a different view of
stuff that Sasha has said that there are
these data agnostic mechanisms and that
they that almost all of them fit a
certain form so now like if we just
invoke the Laplace targeting mechanism
we could take our workload and we can
certainly answer it and we get workload
answers with noise and one of the
motivations that started started our our
work on this was that one byproduct here
is that these Korean sirs are
inconsistent so you can get results like
the number of people under 30 plus the
number of people over 30 is not equal to
the noisy estimate of the total number
of your population okay and this is
distressing for people who look at the
results so consistency was one of our
motivations but in addition if you
the workload composed in the way I
described on the on the next slide the
workload could be high sensitivity there
could be a lot of noise and you'd like
to find something to do that's better so
these data agnostic mechanisms a lot of
them what they do and as we learned in
the matrix mechanism they interpose a
separate set of measurements they add
they invoke the Gaussian or Laplace
mechanism on those and then they and
then you have noisy measurements but not
the noisy measurements you want so you
need to get estimates to the workload
queries and you'd like those to be
consistent
okay so we'll call this another name for
this is sort of like this the Select
measure and reconstruct paradigm I'll
refer to it that way you don't
necessarily have to solve a hard
optimization problem to select
measurements maybe you just have insight
into your workload for example we
learned that the threshold queries which
we call the prefix queries are you know
a nice set of measurements for those are
these this hierarchical tree thing okay
and then we try then we'll reconstruct
them now one thing that that didn't
arise in in Sasha's presentation is that
we when we were doing this we and a lot
of the empirical work there's a
principle here by which we chose to
reconstruct there's obviously more than
one way to take these noisy measurements
and to reconstruct answers to the
workload queries and our way of doing it
was sort of like minimizing the squared
error between you know using these as
evidence and deriving the H histogram
that is sort of like that minimizes the
the squared error given your your
evidence okay and then once you have the
h histogram which we're gonna call x so
now if we were good tutorial designers
we would have like unified all of the
notation and everything and we didn't do
that because it's an assorted an
experiential thing this is what it's
like to be split between the theory and
applied world where the variable names
don't line up H becomes ax little n
becomes big n and yeah
this is like a longer answer don't don't
you can feel free to come about but why
is the thing you describe not like
exactly the projection mechanism so I'll
show describe like you finding the
closest set of answers given the
generations no are you reconstructing
the vector of outputs or I think it's
because we're fixing a reconstruction I
think we talked about this a little bit
I think it's because we're fixing a
reconstruction method and at least an
ARFF reconstructing the histogram versus
reconstructing the query answers if I
see girls my projection like uses the
factor no Obama the databases that I
think it matter okay so with ones
projecting on the subspace in areas
which is easy and get it for projecting
all these electronics how it's like
polytope which is quickly hard another
question that you try to then reconcile
across would that be within one of the
crews across that would be for for
results computed on a single database
whatever you want to call a snapshot in
time of the database you'd like this
statistics to be consistent no matter
when I do this it's not like this is one
query that I sent
you do this today and I do this like
three months from now it would still be
consistent well I mean we'll invoke our
will invoke our mechanisms on a single
database which represents a snapshot in
time and then I want this which is a
potentially large set of statistics
about that database to be internally
consistent in the sense that even though
there's noise added to them there there
exists a DAT a single database from
which all of those workload queries
could could be derived so you know you
there's lots of intuitions intuitions
here you can think of this as a kind of
compilation compilation procedure if
anybody is encountered experimental
design this is essentially a lot like an
experimental design problem where you're
trying to figure out an unseen vector X
and you've got some constraints on what
you can measure about X it's just sort
of like unusual constraints that arise
from from privacy experimental design
that's been studied elsewhere
okay so there's been lots of work that
can be viewed in this paradigm of select
measure and reconstruct and there's
basically you know it differs unlike it
was targeting certain types of workloads
maybe marginals or one-dimensional range
queries and these fixed methods are
basically matched a strategy or a set of
measurements that worked well for a
fixed workload okay so it's sort of like
there's no hard optimization problem
it's just an observation that if you if
you're if you care about one dimensional
range queries it's good to form trees of
measurements and then you can do
reconstruction efficiently okay so we'll
come back to this or if you're doing two
dimensional range view you do two
dimensional quadtree type stuff and then
there's another you know and then that
grew into the matrix mechanism and the
other other things that tried to solve
an optimization problem that said
whatever you know subset of this class
of workload queries is I
we'll try to solve for a good strat
strategy okay so let me I want to just
walk through some of the intuition here
because for the workload that motivated
our early work in this area which was
range Greece and we talked about this
again I want to show show you a slightly
different example so if you want to
answer the set of all range queries you
know that that workload has high
sensitivity has a lot of queries about N
squared over 2 in where n is the domain
size and one measurement set you could
clearly use is is called the identity
I'll show you a picture of this such as
means measure each element of the unseen
vector X and get a noisy estimate from
that and then you can derive you know
easily reconstruct answers to your range
queries another another work in this
area observe that if you use
measurements that are derived from a
hard wavelet you get good performance on
range queries and we and and people also
tried --try based things so let me show
show you what these things look like now
in these are this is a strategy matrix
and remember that the rows are each
going to be measurements ok so I'm going
to multiply each row against my data
vector which is size 4 and so the
identity matrix is saying estimate the
first component of the unseen data
vector then estimate the second one in
the third and the fourth okay you get
noisy estimates to each of those where
is this hierarchical thing this is
analogous to the tree that Sasha showed
us where the first measurement is really
the sum of each of the components in the
unseen vector and then we kind of
decompose and we sum the the leftmost to
and then the rightmost to and then we
have the identity matrix as a sort of
sub matrix here ok and the observation
there is that you can reconstruct any
range query from logarithmic ly many s
noisy estimates ok because the problem
is that the noise added to each of these
measurements is independent and when you
saw when you use a lot of those
estimates and sum them together the
variance accumulates
now this wavelet thing is doesn't look
much like a tree but it has a similar
aspects it has the observation which
sums all the elements and then it kind
of decomposes things in a binary way but
it's actually taking the difference
between the right hafta and the left
half and then the difference between
these two cells in these two cells okay
so if so the art or the goal of of
choosing a strategy for your workload is
you know it should have low sensitivity
but if we just wanted low sensitivity we
would do this because the sensitivity is
the absolute column norm alright the
maximum absolute column norm alright
these have these two strategies have
higher sensitivity but they support
efficient reconstruction and just two so
this is what happens sort of empirically
if you run these and you look at so mean
squared error so higher error on the
y-axis and you look at the range queries
and I've organized that them by the
width of the query okay as a fraction of
the domain size and what you see is with
identity the larger the query the larger
the error and that with these
hierarchical techniques and wavelet
you're getting very similar performance
in what you do is you pay a price for
the small queries you would have done
better for small queries if you had
asked identity because as lower
sensitivity and small Crees don't you
don't need to add too many things up so
the variance doesn't accumulate right so
but for the large queries you would do
very badly with identity and this is
sort of substantially dampened by these
hierarchical techniques so actually the
hierarchical technique was a paper that
we wrote and then somebody else like
almost at the same time wrote this paper
on Waveland they were both targeting
differentially private answering of
range queries and we were we were really
curious to understand how you know I
mean we didn't have this graph so they
look almost identical in performance and
we were trying to understand you know
but also the wavelet stuff you know was
actually described as a transformation
where you take your data vector you
transform it by a wavelet transformation
then you apply the Laplace mechanism and
you transform things back so it's a
little bit of a different language but
really we it started at us asking
questions like well if these are two
comparable approaches to range queries
sort of which one's better and are they
optimal and and stuff like that and one
interesting tidbit here is that if you
take the wavelet measurement matrix it
turns out to be equivalent exactly
equivalent as a measurement matrix to
this thing okay and which is which is
which is interesting but if you if you
you know know a lot about differential
privacy especially epsilon different for
privacy and applying the Laplace
mechanism you see that what you have is
sort of like redundant measurements
you've measured this cell twice
you usually get penalized for that under
epsilon differential privacy for
measuring we're asking the same query
twice
you're better off actually asking that
query once and adding some weight to it
okay so this actually has the same sort
of like it distributes error the same
way but the sensitivity is reduced and
so you can show that as a strategy for
answering range queries this little
matrix is you know dominates this one
all right so just to show you that
there's sort of subtleties here and that
there's nothing special about wavelet
the wavelet matrix and it's actually not
optimal so the question is like what's
optimal and can we find it okay so that
sort of motivated the matrix mechanism
in our formulation of it which is you
know if your which is the following
one-liner and I think it just makes
sense to show you compared with this so
this is the Laplace mechanism applied to
the workload you multiply the workload
matrix times the data vector which is ax
not H remember and then you you take a
vector of independent laplace noise and
scale this by the sensitivity in epsilon
alright so that's the standard Laplace
mechanism this is a little bit different
but not so different if you if we look
at it this way these are the two answers
to the workload queries
this is the noise transformed by this w
a pseudo-inverse okay so this is sort of
like and then scaled but not by the
sensitivity the workload by the
sensitivity to strategy matrix so that's
how we achieve some of the savings of
reducing sensitivity of the strategy
matrix okay so this has closed form
errors so there's an error expression
which given the workload and a strategy
matrix we can compute the error and this
is similar to what we saw before this is
the total squared error across the
workload and the data is not in here
anywhere okay so we can we know what
error we're gonna get for any for any
database and that's a nice feature okay
unfortunately it's hard to find the
optimal strategy in our form formulation
it's got a lot of parameters the
pseudo-inverse is in expensive to
compute and not well behaved the
constraints are hard to encode and it's
really not not smooth okay so we never
we were never able to solve this in
practice you know for anything so it was
interesting to study we you know there
were attempts I mean we we we described
in the original paper how you could
solve this that it was like an SDP with
rank constraints this is for the l1 case
or for epsilon differential privacy and
that that you could you could put it
into SDP form but you know n here little
n is the domain size for us that the
size of this vector so even getting it
into the form of a convex optimization
problem it's just still completely
infeasible for interesting examples okay
so this is a simplification of an
attempt to find a set of data cube
queries that doesn't really compute the
true error metric and this is the low
rank mechanism so I'm not going to go
into detail with these but we're going
to come back to this so so so that's
where we that's where we were with with
the data agnostic algorithms that are
in instances of this we're select
measure reconstruct paradigm all right
there are lots of examples from the
applied literature there are instances
of that all sort of implicitly doing
this least-squares reconstruction so the
second approach which I'll mention
briefly and then come back to at the end
assuming I have time does something a
little bit different so we've got the
workload as input and then I sort of
describe this try to put these things on
the same footing by saying that there's
some tests done or some modeling of the
data done as a as an initial stage which
is then used later to choose or
influence the measurements that are
taken and then noise is added to those
and then maybe there's reconstruction
okay so this is like an extension of
select measure and reconstruct where and
this could this whole thing could be
iterated but where we test or model the
data set now the intuitions that are
embodied in this class of mechanisms are
that there are some there are some times
or situations where we know that we
shouldn't try to measure something and
first and and that's a data dependent
thing and if we can detect that and we
might have to do so privately so Meuse
some of our privacy budget to detect
that then we shouldn't measure those
things okay so in the multiplicative
weights exponential mechanism algorithm
I guess you could say that the the sort
of like inspiration is they don't
measure stuff you already know or your
current estimate is good enough for this
query so don't spend more of your
privacy budget learning more about the
answer to that query there are some
other techniques that try to learn
something like so it's so another thing
that we sort of informally know is that
at it at certain epsilon so you're not
going to be able to really differentiate
sort of like small counts from one
another or small differences and counts
from one another so you sort of
shouldn't try another thing that that
these algorithms do is often they
we'll try to detect regions in the
domain if this is like a one-dimensional
histogram they might try to say you know
what actually this region looks pretty
uniform and I could approximate it well
by just as you assuming uniformity so if
I can detect that ahead of time I won't
try to measure you know the individual
components here or range queries in this
region I will simply measure the total
sum of all of these buckets and and then
stop measuring things within that region
and you can increase you can lower the
variants substantially by techniques
like that but you introduce bias okay oh
and also I want to point out I I I
talked to mark Oh about this so I
wouldn't feel too bad but dual query is
an algorithm that doesn't really fit
well into this into this set of
categories so I sort of like I'm not
doing it justice we may come back to
that at the end okay so there's a number
of applied works that are embodying
these principles of sort of like testing
something about the data that will then
influence the measurements taken and
then maybe do some reconstruction so
this is the multiplet of weights
algorithm these these algorithms are for
the most part doing types of things
where they detect how much how large the
counts are and they sort of like they
tree structure things but where you cut
off the bottom of the tree when the
counts are too small because you sort of
realize that you can't you don't have
enough signal to make measurements worth
taking these this technique is similar
to like finding regions that are well
approximant afore MIDI and then you
could think of this as modeling the data
imposing a model on the data which says
this region is is is you assumed uniform
in this region is assuming the uniform
this technique privately learns the
structure of a Bayes net that would fit
the data well and then in a subsequent
step
measures the statistics that underlie
the the Bayes net and then does some
reconstruction and then there's dual
query which I guess you could say you
know chooses tries to measure minimum
payoff records or something like that
okay so if we try to compare these in
the data agnostic world a lot of things
look like select measure measure
reconstruct oh and although there are
different ways to reconstruct there to
me they seem sort of like it's a more
orderly set of techniques whereas in the
data adaptive world there's there's more
variety one really nice feature of data
agnostic techniques that I've mentioned
is that the workload query error is
easily computable in most cases and it's
non sensitive so we can tell we can
release the query the answers to the
workload queries and closed form
estimates of error and that whereas with
the data adaptive techniques oftentimes
we can't compute the error readily we
can't predict it because it depends on
the data so this and and and so we would
have to you know use some of our privacy
budget to release error bounds and those
those those expected error rates would
be themselves noisy and so in practice
this can you know cause some some some
challenges so in the data agnostic world
also we have unbiased query answers you
know which is to say that the expected
value that we get out for our workload
query answers equals the true answer
whereas that's not true for many of the
data adaptive techniques and that's also
a problem in practice because we have
systematically biased out outputs coming
out of some of these algorithms our
empirical study that I'll get to a
little of this at the end of the talk we
have time shows what what what what's
actually hinted at that if you have a
lot of signal meaning you've been
granted a high privacy budget or you
have a lot of data then the data
agnostic techniques tend to outperform
we
if you have very low signal low a little
data not very much data or small Epsilon
the data adaptive techniques tend to
outperform at least that that's true in
the low dimensional settings and we
haven't studied the high dimensional
settings as rigorously yet now both of
these approaches have scalability
challenges the biggest one in the data
agnostic setting is that is this
reliance on sort of materializing the
data vector which is you know
exponential in this domain sizes of or
the product of the domain sizes of the
attributes and so it can really break
down for high dimensional data and
they're also scalability so it's a
little bit of a mixed picture with the
data adaptive mechanisms some of them
that are trying to model the data
privately model the data these some of
these techniques really don't scale very
well especially for large data vectors
but then we also have things like dual
query and the Preveza in the bait
learning the Bayes net that really do
scale well so so it's it's it's not it's
it's not it's not sort of uniform okay
so any questions about this and I'll
transition to the census example this
yeah okay all right so I want to I'm
gonna so I'm kind of kind of stay in the
data agnostic select measure reconstruct
paradigm and talk about the census
example which is which is sort of a live
challenge that we're facing
so the census as many of you know is
testing out differentially private
algorithms for release of some of their
key statistics coming out of the 2020
census in summary file one is one of
their major data products
it describes persons that is people but
they're called persons at the census and
how they are grouped into households
which are just groups of persons with a
head of household and usually kids and
extended family we're not going to talk
about households households are
complicate complicated we're going to
talk about queries over persons and keep
things simple and I'm going to refer to
summary file one as SF one and the
schema for this data looks something
like this so we have sax male and female
relation which is the relationship that
you have to the householder you could be
the householder itself or you could be a
sibling or a child or parent or
something like that ages from 1 to 115
so there's 17 different relationships to
householder you could have race and
ethnicity which there's 63 different
race combinations you can because you
can be more than one you can be multiple
races there's like six race categories
but you can be any permutation of you
can be all six or any subset of those
and then you can be Hispanic or not
Hispanic so that works out to 126
different race ethnicity combinations so
these are what I refer to as sort of the
demographic properties those are
composed with Geographic so we can
measure how many people are a hundred
and fifteen years old and male at any at
a number of levels of geography we could
ask that at in the whole nation or we
could ask that you know at a state level
or a census tract or a census block
to the smallest sort of roughly
equivalent to a city block and there's
like 11 million of those so now we think
you know this is where this is where the
data the whole notion of turning a
relational relational representation of
data into a vector representation where
in a histogram starts to really break
down okay so I have the domain sizes on
the next slide but this seven hundred
page document which you can read it's
freely available online describes
exactly exactly the tabulations that are
made public they're called tables which
I which which I hate because I'm a
database guy they're not tables they're
I guess there are contingency tables is
sort of what they are they're like a
weird weird form of contingency table
and we you know if you just look at the
more basic there's a lot there's more
than 4151 counting queries if you
include household stuff but if you just
look at the ones that talk about persons
there's about 4,000 of those and that's
a workload okay so that's a lecture
actually a very nicely encoded I mean
except that it's a PDF document and
there's 700 pages that you have to read
it's precise and it's a workload just
like of predicate queries exactly right
I really
what I well I guess what I mean is that
there's some ways in which it's nested
that I that I think are not standard for
contingency tables but contingency
tables as is not it's not my home domain
I have to admit you would take all these
variables that let's say they were
treating them all as spending or Nicole
so I forgot how many of you listed there
up eight or something like that and
basically we would say the product of
all eight of them even to get like
giving themselves and then we need at
one massive logistic table that would be
another point that you can arrive in
wonderful queue but you can take only
three of the variables cross classify
and record the number of individuals
each of these tables and that's a good
typical contingency table right but
there's no hierarchy there than you
store and I think in some of these
tables and maybe volcanoes better they
are I think there are many different
tables that could you
right and some of these tables have
certain associations and hierarchy
things that's not if you got rid of like
the states and tracks which have a
hierarchical relationship yeah well but
so attracts right if you got rid of
stadium tracks it would basically so let
me come back to this because in a few
minutes I'll describe the structure for
this workload and then and I think it'll
become clear what's a little bit out of
it so if we just look at the demographic
properties the domain size here is about
half a million okay and we sometimes say
this is we've ignored geography or we've
like aggregated up to the national level
okay and if we want to extend down we
connect we can get much larger domain
sizes or histogram sizes we would have
25 million values if we just did all of
these demographic possibilities times
the 52 states and then we get of
histogram this size if we include full
geography okay all right so now we think
about like okay let's run the matrix
mechanism except that the sdp we have to
solve is over a workload matrix with the
number of columns equal to 25 million
and and so so we're we're in trouble
the nice thing yes yes there are yeah
oh that you could omit and shrink this
yes and that's something that the
question was are there structural zeros
at the person level and so there are
things like people who are age 5 should
not be grandparents and so they
shouldn't have a relationship to
householder which is which is
grandparent done you should definitely
have a zero for all of the at every
level of job you know so there are
things like that and there and they're
trying that but it's I don't think it's
gonna dramatically change the dynamics
of the problem okay so what I want to
describe is the structure in these
workloads so I'm going to define a
product workload as a kind of like cross
product of these can bullying conditions
on attributes so if I if I describe a
kind of sub
workload on age which is saying I have
one condition which is age greater than
18 they don't have to be independent but
age equal to 65 age in this range and
then I have some other conditions on
race and I take the cross-product of
these I will put the condition I'll pair
the conditions together in all possible
ways and conjunct them okay and this
allows me to you know this is exactly
what's happening with marginal so you
should think of this workload the census
workload is like a generalization of
marginals marginals our product
workloads where the sets of conditions
are either the identity meaning that
it's an enumeration of every domain
element for age 1 through 150 115 or
it's just totally like marginalizing out
over the attribute and saying I don't
care what your relationship is and I'm
gonna aggregate over it okay so this is
a two-way marginal on as a product
workload on age and race this is one of
the tables where it has this nested
structure where that asks for the total
population actually every table contains
the total population and then how many
males there are and then break down
males by those that are under five five
to nine ten to fourteen and so on okay
so that's this table p12 written as a
product alright
so product workloads can encode the
Cartesian product of counting queries so
all multi-racial range queries a single
marginal or maybe all marginals and if
we we might need to encode we might want
to encode a workload that's just a union
a combination of multiple product
workloads we just say that's a union of
products okay so that could be arbitrary
collections of multi-dimensional range
queries collections of marginals or the
sf1 file which can be encoded as the
union of 32 product workloads there's
other ways to encode it the sensitivity
turns out to be 50 now and I'm almost
done I have two more slides before the
suspenseful break that will take so this
is not a complete enumeration but this
is sort of like
some of the tables expressed as product
so this is like identity on sex with
some course age ranges and then
marginalizing out race and ethnicity and
relationship and if we include geography
we go to the block level okay now this
is dud then there's a table that's like
only cares about under-20 people of both
sexes race and ethnicity and
relationship doesn't matter at the block
level okay and then something else at
the track level now this one is
important
notice that this says doesn't care about
Sachs cares about race and ethnicity and
this is race combinations this is like
all the enumeration of all possible
races plus these weird conditions on
like are you two or more races are you
three or more races
it aggregates those things and then it
only cares about whether you're over 18
doesn't care about what anybody have a
hint at what why this is an important
tabulation voting they're counting the
ethnicity of vote of voting age persons
which is really important for
redistricting because it's the basis of
the redistricting data there's a special
law that governs this that's given out
at special times and it's important that
it be accurate okay that's a little
foreshadowing because I want to
eventually raise the question of if this
is the whole workload but this product
workload this particular product is
really important we might need to weight
it or something we might want to devote
more of our privacy budget to it or
something like that okay but we could do
that if we could run the matrix
mechanism because we could weight things
but there's a problem these objects are
really big so this was the matrix
mechanism in in sort of algorithmic form
where we have to look at the steps and
when things break down so this is the
census table that we would take in and
we would vectorize it to get our data
vector the problem is the data vectors
big even at the national level it's a
you know we said half a million at the
state level ten to the seventh okay so
it's getting really big so we're worried
then we have to materialise our workload
matrix because that's how we're gonna
feed into the optimization problem
oh boy because then we have 4000 queries
times the domain size so at the national
level that's an 8 gigabyte matrix at the
state level it's 22 terabytes
all right and this is the thing that
that Sasha wants you to run an SDP on
sorry this single us so then we have to
solve the optimization problem and then
we should also not forget that we have
to do reconstruction which might involve
a pseudo inverse of this measurement
matrix or something that we and that
could also be a problem
so the suspenseful question is how could
we ever run this algorithm at this scale
can we will we be able to you got to
come back after the coffee break
[Applause]
[Music]